.
Sébastien Desrosiers.
- So, where's your house?
- That white one right there.
- Cette résidente d'Abbotsford
devra prendre un bateau si
elle veut retourner chez elle.
Sa maison, comme bien d'autres
ici, est pratiquement submergée.
Les pompes ne réussissent pas
encore à évacuer l'eau.
Tous n'ont pas un bateau,
mais ceux qui en ont un offrent
leur aide. Ils naviguent dans
Tous n'ont pas un bateau,
mais ceux qui en ont un offrent
leur aide. Ils naviguent dans
ce qui était, il y a quelques
jours, des rues et des champs.
- We got one cat and two dogs!
- Ils vont secourir des animaux
qui sont restés derrière.
Ces chiens n'ont pas mangé
depuis trois jours.
Comme l'explique le député
d'Abbotsford Sud, des équipes
tentent de colmater les brèches
dans les digues qui ont cédé
pour retenir l'eau qui continue
de s'écouler jusqu'ici.
Cette zone d'Abbotsford,
qui était un lac il y a
une centaine d'années,
le lac Sumas, est aujourd'hui
complètement inondée.
Plus de 600 personnes
ont dû être évacuées en
toute urgence cette semaine.
Et les autorités espèrent faire
baisser le niveau d'eau le plus
rapidement possible, notamment
pour permettre la réouverture
de la route Transcanadienne,
qui donne accès à l'est de
la province et au reste du pays.
What's planned for
the rest of the day?
Mais tant que l'eau ne sera pas
retirée, il faudra continuer de
se serrer les coudes et prendre
les journées une à la fois.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, A